-Our next guest is the
award-winning and best-selling
author of the book
"Say Nothing,"
as well as a staff writer
at "The New Yorker."
His new book,
"Empire of Pain:
The Secret History
of the Sackler Dynasty,"
is available now.
Please welcome back to the sho
Patrick Radden Keefe.
Hello, Patrick. How are you?
-Hey, great to see you.
-I don't know if you know,
but last night on the show
John Oliver was on
and he very much wanted to use
his time here to plug your book.
So that is
the level of excitement
amongst those of us
who are fans of your work.
-I thought that was so amazing
I heard about it this morning.
I was super psyched,
particularly because
he actually did a segment.
I write in the book
about a segment he did
on his show
about the Sackler family.
-Well, that's probably why
he was excited about it,
is he just wanted to see
his name in print.
-It's fairly typical of him,
I'd say.
-Yeah, I mean, you know the guy.
That all he's about.
So, one of the things,
the last time you were here,
talking about
your book "Say Nothing,"
I remember us speaking
after it was over
and you saying this is
what you're working on next.
And, obviously,
a great deal of research
has to go into a book like this.
And a pandemic, it turns out
will hamstring some effort
so far as research is concerned.
But people being at home
turned out to be advantageous.
-Yeah, it was a funny thing.
So, I had been gathering
lots of documents,
going to archives, and suddenl
found that I was shut down
I actually had a pretty
interesting 2020 lined up,
and I was doing
"Say Nothing" stuff.
And podcasting, I was working on
"Wind of Change."
And then basically all of my
plans got canceled for a yea
and I ended up stuck at home
But I did find that the --
people pick up the phone
when you call them
during a pandemic,
which, for a reporter,
is actually pretty helpful
-And do you think people,
because they were maybe
so thirsty for human contact
were they more talkative
than they would have been
during a different time?
-Way more talkative.
The worst thing
about being a reporter
is cold-calling people,
particularly when all you have
is their home number --
right? -- their landline,
which people just generall
won't pick up.
I did find that once
the pandemic started,
on the first ring, people
were immediately picking u
and eager to tell you thei
secrets and their stories --
anything for some company.
-"The New York Times" reported
that you did write this book
in bed.
Is that a true fact?
-This is a true fact.
You'll notice I'm coming to yo
here from my nice home offic
that I share with my wife.
But my wife has a real job
And so when the pandemic hit
she started working from here.
And I ended up working from bed.
-So, this is about
the Sackler family
and their company,
Purdue Pharma,
which was behind
the creation of OxyContin.
And basically
the opioid epidemic
can be laid at their feet.
Now, one thing
that's fascinating
about reading this book is
from way, decades earlier,
when they first
got involved
in this pharmaceutical company
they always appreciated
the value
of keeping the Sackler nam
away from the actual
pharmaceutical company.
What was it that made them think
that was so valuable
from, you know, years ago?
-This was the thing
I found so fascinating.
Looking back, to some extent
the OxyContin story
from recent decades is familiar.
But, for me, looking back
at history of this family,
going back to the 1950s,
you saw that there was
this weird thing
where they had a kind of mania
for putting their name
on buildings, on museums,
on university halls.
My favorite example is,
if you go to London
to the Tate Modern, there'
an escalator you can ride on
and you get to the top
of the escalator
and there's a sign saying that
"You are riding
on the Sackler escalator."
So there is this tendency
to put the name on all of thes
philanthropic gifts
but to keep it off
of the family business.
So you have
this weird phenomenon
where I think, for a long time
there was a sense of this
as this very generous, kind of
elite, wealthy dynasty.
But nobody really knew
where the money came from.
And it turns out,
it's from this,
I think, quite often,
sordid pharma business.
-One of the things
that was fascinating to me
because it's maybe even more -
I don't know if "insidious
is right word --
but a more important invention
insofar as how
pharmaceutical companies
influence doctors,
is the Sackler family was really
at the forefront of that.
They were an advertising famil
that basically started
advertising pharmaceutical
in a way
that we still see
very much today.
Is that something you knew
going into it?
-It's not, and I was
so intrigued by this.
So, Arthur Sackler
was the oldest
of the original three brothers
He was, like, the Don Draper
of medical advertising
in the 1950s.
He had
a medical advertising firm
and he devised all these ways --
He basically realized
that the consumer,
like you or me,
that's not the person
you're trying to win over.
What you want to win over
is the doctor
who's writing the prescription
and so he came up
with all these ways
of influencing doctors.
And it's funny 'cause
if you talk to doctors,
if you know doctors,
they'll often say,
"Oh, I would never be influenced
by a pharmaceutical company.
But to give an example
with Purdue Pharma,
this company spent
$9 million a year
just on buying food for doctors.
And you have to assume
that they were looking
at whether or not
they were gonna get
a return on their investment
And there are studies on this.
If they go out and buy
a steak dinner for a docto
or even a lunch on the go,
they can influence
the way that doctor prescribes
-You even talk about this
in the book,
but, obviously, you had to
go into it expecting it.
It certainly came to pass
to be true.
You received
a great deal of blowback
from the Sackler family.
Was it more than you even
expected, going into it?
-More than I've ever
dealt with before.
Yeah, they really didn't wan
this book to be written.
And they didn't
cooperate with me.
Before I even started writing,
they were sending me
these legal letters.
And it got to a point
where I was getting
so many legal letters from them,
it reminded me
of that scene in "Harry Potter
where the letters are, like,
coming in under the door
and down the chimney.
Yeah, I got a lot of them.
I'm still getting them.
We got one just last week
to the publisher.
I keep threatening my wife
that I want to
wallpaper our bathroom wit
legal letters from the Sacklers.
We don't have quite enough yet
-So, even though
the book is out,
they have not stopped trying
to what at this point?
-Well, I think that part
of this story is
about how they were this famil
that made billions and billion
of dollars on OxyContin,
this drug that ends up
sparking the opioid crisis
But they were able
to kind of
write themselves
out of the picture.
And I think that now
that that narrative
is getting corrected --
and it's not just me,
it's other journalists, as well,
that are kind of
putting the family
back into that story,
that's something
that makes them pretty upset
And so they're doing
anything they can
to thwart people like me who try
and tell the truth of that
And when you're worth billions
and billions of dollars,
you have a lot of resources.
You can put a lot of peopl
on the job.
-You also sort of mentione
that this book shouldn't b
the last word on it, but serve
as sort of a jumping-off point
for journalists to continu
to cover this story.
Where would you like them
to explore next?
If you could sort of point
people who write about thi
in any one direction?
-So, the end game is actuall
playing out right now.
And weirdly enough,
it's happening
at a bankruptcy court
in New York.
And before your eyes glaze over,
the way in which this stor
is ending is
that the Sackler family
has taken $10 billion
out of their company,
Purdue Pharma,
and when they've basically
taken all the money out,
they've pushed the company
into bankruptcy,
and say, "Okay, well,
the company is bankrupt now,
but we're going to keep
our money."
And it's in
that bankruptcy court
that we're gonna see
how this ends,
whether they get a permanent
"get out of jail free" car
and there's a bar on any
future lawsuits against them
It's funny you mentioned
John Oliver.
He had a line
that I always think about,
years ago, in a broadcast,
where he said,
"If you want to do
something evil,
wrap it in something boring.
And I feel like bankruptcy court
is the place
where you can carry out
your villainous plans,
because it is
so confusing and complicated
But there's a new piece of
legislation in Congress
that they've actually called
the Sackler Act,
which would prevent
the bankruptcy court
from letting the Sacklers
off the hook.
And so that's pending right now,
and I think
journalists should be lookin
very closely at that case,
because whether or not we ge
real accountability
for the Sacklers will all depend
on what happens
in that court
in the next few months.
-Well, it's nice
that they're getting their nam
on something else, you know?
-[ Chuckles ]
-Not just escalators anymore
-Anymore.
Yeah, they're trading up.
-Hey, thank you.
The book is fantastic.
No surprise there.
We really appreciate
you making the time for us
It's always great to see you
-Oh, thank you so much.
-"Empire of Pain" is available
now wherever books are sold.
But please support
your local and independent
bookstores.